so I just wanted to so I'm going to
quickly quick updates
um I'm assuming nothing has happened
with Star Wars we were just starting the
process of developing my movie and a
writer strike happened so we are we are
in that holding pattern that so much of
our industry is in Real Steel TV series
same I could literally say C above C
above sure um same still I guess I've
told you I want it as badly as the
lovers of Real Steel want it so alive
paused do you think a free guy sequel
actually happens or is it sort of like
this was so good and came out so great
do we want to make another I think it is
definitely not uh assured we love free
guy and the love for free guy that has
kind of resonated in like after shocks
if you will in the last couple years
that's been thrilling to Ryan and I we
are developing a sequel
um but the shoot is it you now have
Barbie that has obviously left to Mark
about a character in a fictional world
who comes to self-awareness so we're
only going to make free guy too if it's
different than the first movie and if
it's different from other movies I'm a
fan of Shadow and Bone
I don't know what's the status of season
three neither do I yet okay I'll leave
it there uh my last question for you um
I know that you always direct episodes
of stranger things when the strike ends
they're obviously going to start filming
stranger things and you're going to be
working on Deadpool do you think you're
actually going to direct any of the
final season like for sure I bleed for
that show
I've been alongside Matt and Ross
stuffer for all these years I direct
episodes every year it's a part of our
Brotherhood it's a part of my commitment
and my love of the show connecting with
it as a director as well as a executive
producer so I will go through hoops to
figure out calendars to direct at least
one episode I was gonna say it's
normally episode three or four but I
don't know if it'll be that's the part
that's up in the air